bonjour et bonne année à tous et surtout
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo version 2013 au parlement
européen à strasbourg
et pour ce premier numéro de l'année
focus sur le mariage homosexuel au
moment où le projet de loi est débattue
en france reportage en belgique où le
mariage entre personnes de même sexe est
autorisé depuis dix ans mais d'abord
l'actualité la france intervient depuis
quelques jours au mali
mais que fait l'europe pour ce théâtre
d'intervention c'est la question de la
semaine
depuis quelques jours déjà les avions de
combat français déchirent le ciel malien
nom de code de l'opération serval face à
une armée malienne exemple les rebelles
ont conquis le nord est ouvert une
brèche vers bamako la capitale
une avancée qui a poussé le président
malien a demandé l'aide de la france
et pendant ce temps à bruxelles
on se réunit on réfléchit on planifie on
continue de préparer l'opération eu une
tm utm
mais qu'est ce donc une simple opération
de formation de l'armée malienne
prévue depuis de nombreux mois elle est
restée dans les cartons mais promis juré
craché
elle arrive lady ashton haute
représentante aux affaires étrangères
auraient-elles saisi l'urgence de la
situation
pas sûr quant à herman van rompuy le
président du conseil européen il estime
qu'il est urgent de stopper les
terroristes
qui provoque beaucoup de souffrance
parmi la population
un peu court non alors que fait l'europe
pour le mali alors à l'heure où les
forces françaises sont engagées au mali
le se pose la question aujourd'hui en
europe de que fait l'europe pour pour
cette intervention nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau marielle de sarnez bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous faites partie de
la délégation paritaire afrique caraïbes
pacifique et l'union européenne
un débat a eu lieu mardi au parlement
sur cette question alors objectivement
aujourd'hui que fait l'europe pour cette
question d'abord si vous me le permettez
je voudrais commencer par dire que ce
qui se passe au mali concerne l'europe
et concerne au fond tous les européens
c'est pas simplement une question pour
mallet pour le mali s'est pas seulement
même une question pour les africains ou
pour le sahel s'est pas seulement une
question pour la france c'est une
question qui concerne la sécurité de
tous les européens et donc c'est très
important que l'europe non seulement
soutiennent politiquement ce qu'elle
fait mais que l'europe montre une
solidarité active c'est à dire en
matière de logistique et en matière peut
être militaire je l'espère demain la
france est en première ligne parce que
nous avons été appelés et vraiment je
soutiens la position française
je soutiens la détermination française à
éradiquer le terrorisme de cette partie
là du monde c'est au fond il faut bien
voir que le mali le nord mali est à
quelques pas c'est à l'entrée de l'union
européenne à l'entrée de l'europe
c'était donc vital pour notre sécurité
que de faire ce que nous faisons sur le
terrain mais il faut que l'europe
au delà du soutien politique évidemment
aille plus loin alors justement vous
avez appelé dans l'hémicycle mardi face
à catherine ashton à une accélération du
programme utm donc il ya un programme en
fait de formation pour l'armée malienne
est-ce que ça paraît pas dérisoire
finalement alors que l'armée malienne
est déjà sur le terrain en train de
combat évidemment que ça paraît et
damman avec beaucoup de lenteur et que
ça aurait été beaucoup mieux que ce soit
fait depuis longtemps puisque ça fait
maintenant plus d'un an que nous parlons
d'une stratégie pour le sahel
ici au parlement européen donc il ya eu
un retard et on voit bien que au fond
l'europe de la défense elle n'existe pas
que l'europe de la sécurité elle est
aussi à construire aussi à bâtir et que
ce qu'il faut bâtir dans les mois et les
années qui viennent ce que nous cessons
de dire nous européens c'est au fond une
robe de la volonté qu'on est réellement
une politique étrangère et qu'on ait les
moyens de défendre les valeurs et dans
laquelle nous croyons les 10 h nom de
cette politique étrangère non mais voilà
lady ashton elle fait ce qu'elle peut
c'est à dire pas grand chose avait
cofondé pays qui gardent leur politique
étrangère et je le comprends il va aussi
quelquefois de l'intérêt national d'un
pays mais il faut en même temps qu'on
est une europe qui pèse davantage
alors heureusement on a quelques pays la
grande bretagne par exemple qui sont aux
côtés de la france est très important
parce qu'au fond en terme de défense on
a deux pays importants en europe 1 c'est
la france et la grande bretagne que la
grande bretagne soit aux côtés de la
france c'est bien
se pose aussi la question de l'otan nous
sommes rentrés dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan
très critique avec françois n'est pas
conseillé au fond nous sommes dans le
commandement intégré de l'otan et que
fait l'otan pour le mani j'attends de le
voir aussi mais il ya aussi un autre
problème c'est que on a affaire quand
même à des critiques par rapport à
l'union vous disiez vous même il ya une
espèce d'europe de la défense qui est en
panne on parle d'europe à responsabilité
limitée pardon finalement à quelques
jours d du cinquantenaire du traité de
l'élysée qui vous ya vu la coopération
renforcée entre l'allemagne et la france
l'allemagne est quasi absente de cette
question les soutiens sont strictement
politique tout le monde salue l'action
de la france mais finalement on est
prêtes à un petit soutien logistique un
petit soutien humanitaire soutien
médical
est-ce qu'on a les moyens en france
aujourd'hui d'avoir un théâtre de guerre
comme celui là seule écoute et en tous
les cas j'ai confiance est évidemment
dans l'armée française c'est très
important alors ensuite il faut que les
européens à soit aux côtés de cette
armée française
il faut que les armées africaines
s'organise alors on
bien que tout ça pour un peu de temps
mais enfin on a l'ensemble des pays de
la région qui sont enfin en train de se
mobiliser
on va avoir le soutien aussi américains
c'est très important également notamment
en matière de renseignement et de drones
ces avions qui survolent et qui peuvent
nous dire exactement ce qui se passe
localement
parce que c'est suffisant finalement
objectivement écoutez moi j'assume le
fait que la france soit en première
ligne ensuite je fais partie de ceux et
de celles qui demandent depuis des
années que l'europe franchissent un pas
supplémentaire pour devenir une vraie
puissance et ben ça ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ça veut dire ou ne rendra
des causes
ça veut dire en tous les cas une plus
grande et une meilleure coordination en
terme de défense ça veut dire qu'il faut
que l'europe puisse exprimer avoir une
politique étrangère puisse parler d'une
seule voix et donc ça veut dire quand
même forme institutionnelle de l'europe
et ça veut dire surtout une volonté
affirmée afficher des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de considérer que ensemble
nous pesons davantage que séparément
mais donc ça veut dire aussi abandonner
une part des prérogatives nationales non
je crois que c'est très important
l'europe c'est pas remplacer les dations
l'europe c'est au fond faire en sorte
que toutes ces nations ensemble puisse
peser dans le monde tel qu'il est on a
besoin d'un pôle de stabilité et on a
besoin de ce pôle de stabilité et les
moyens de se faire entendre et de
défendre ce en quoi nous croyons
profondément ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
au sahel
ça met en cause pas seulement la
sécurité comme je le disais tout à
l'heure ça met en cause aussi les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres quand on
voit ce que les djihadistes ont depuis
des mois et des mois dans cette région
du monde flageller lapider exécuté
condamné nous voyons bien que tout ça
est bien loin de ce à quoi nous croyons
la question du terrorisme c'est pas
seulement une question pour la france je
le dis pour les européens qui nous
entendent c'est une question qui
concerne toute l'europe et tous les
européens et donc oui j'attends que les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens parce que c'est à ce niveau là
que ça doit se passer que ça doit se
déclenche et prennent la mesure de tout
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au mali au
sahel alors autre actualité on a vu
l'irlande prendre la présidence
tournante de
européenne depuis le 1er janvier il a
fait partie ce pays a fait partie des
pigs ces cochons de la zone euro comme
on les a appelés un peu un peu
cyniquement il fondait beaucoup de mal
exactement et la gagne et je suis allé
deux fois et honnêtement ce qu'ils ont
fait pour se redresser c'est très bien
alors est-ce que vous marielle de sarnez
anton vice-présidente du groupe de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe
est ce que vous êtes confiant dans
l'année 2013 mario draghi le président
de la bce a indiqué qu'il voyait des
signes de reprises pourtant on voit que
en allemagne le
le pib décroche que l'italie donne
encore des signes de faiblesse que
jaurès côté que en tous les cas pour
mario draghi et la baiss e ce qu'ils
font est extrêmement utile qu'il y a eu
quelques signaux positifs par exemple
une eau bancaire en fin de l'année
dernière enfin on va avoir peut-être
garantie des dépôts bancaires garanties
européennes c'est extrêmement important
et que tout ce qui s'est passé pendant
la crise financière avec les banques ne
puissent pas se reproduire cet important
en même temps on est encore loin du
compte
à la vérité on a besoin de plus d'europe
et de mieux d'europe ça posera la
question d'ailleurs de la démocratie en
europe
les citoyens ont le sentiment que les
décisions européennes entre guillemets
prises à bruxelles finalement c'est pas
leurs décisions en l'europe c'est nous
et donc il faut recréer cette intimité
avec l'europe
ils mettent davantage de démocratie je
suis choqué un président de l'europe qui
soit président et de la commission et du
conseil et qui soit élue à terme par les
citoyens au suffrage universel
le même jour que l'élection européenne
qu'il y ait deux zones on vote d'une
part pour ceux qui vous représente au
parlement européen
et puis d'autre part pour ceux qui au
fond vous donner les impulsions
nécessaires à l'europe pour les cinq
années qui viennent on a besoin vital
mans d'une nouvelle démocratie en europe
mais écoutez on est tendance et aussi
une partie du programme de la
présidentielle il y en a un dont merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir rendu
visite
nous on continue justement sur cette
présidence irlandaise qui a occupé
beaucoup de nos confrères européens
un petit tour des télévisions étrangères
c'est avec aurélie la face
objectif numéro un
remettre l'économie européenne sur des
rails accord sur le budget coordination
des politiques économiques et union
bancaire programme chargé en perspective
l'irlande pays sauvé dès novembre 2010
assume aujourd'hui la présidence
semestrielle de l'union européenne le
gouvernement enda kenny a six mois pour
essayer de compléter l'union bancaire
une fois les termes de la supervision
unique approuvé il sera essentiel
d'aborder la création d'un fonds de
garantie des dépôts et d'un fonds de
résolution
ce sera la clé pour arriver au plus vite
à la recapitalisation tant souhaitée des
banques sauver la zone euro
une mission est idéal pour l'irlande
selon la télévision allemande irlandais
pour la plupart d'entre nous l'exemple
parfait de comment résoudre une crise
européenne et on lui demande maintenant
d'être le régulateur de l'union le
premier ministre irlandais paraît être
un bon leader pour l'union européenne
parfait pour mener des procédures
complexes comme le fardeau de la
réglementation de rigueur et pour
maintenir l'union soudés dans ses
relations délicates avec le voisin
britannique et l'optimisme allemand
n'est pas forcément partagé la
présidence de l'union ça ne parle pas à
tout le monde en irlande
c'est grave c'est que nous avons six
mois pour faire bonne impression dans
les autres pays européens sur 27 nations
je pense que nous avons l'opportunité
espérons le de résoudre la crise
bancaire
de façon générale je pense que ça ne va
rien changer
même le pouvoir est toujours en
allemagne
et pour évoquer avec nous la présidence
de l'irlande à la tête de l'europe
depuis ce 1er janvier c'est jean
sébastien lefebvre qui nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste euractiv.fr un site bien
connu qui traite au quotidien des
problématiques européennes alors
l'irlande je les dis auparavant c'est un
membre des pigs les cochons de la zone
euro qui ont eu pour beaucoup dont des
problèmes de dette
est ce que c'est un peu une revanche
cette pré cette présidence quel est le
programme et escaut fonds irlandais
sorti d'affaires une revanche on peut
pas vraiment dire ça puisque les
présidences sont définis très longtemps
à l avance donc c'est juste le
calendrier on va dire le hasard qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la présidence revient à
l'irlande mais c'est un signal assez
fort parce que on a vu mercredi 7
janvier le premier ministre irlandais
devant le parlement européen où il a
affiché son optimisme par rapport à la
situation irlandaise et s'est présenté
vraiment comme le bon élève des pays qui
ont été sauvés durant la période 2010
2011 et il a dit clairement on espère
que d'ici la fin de l'année
l'irlande sortent du de la zone de
turbulences mais surtout du programme de
sauvetage ça veut dire ils ont fini de
faire leurs devoirs et du coup ils
pourront redevenir fiable et aller sur
les marchés cherché chercher directement
d'argent
le premier ministre irlandais demande
aussi une renégociation de la dette
irlandaise
oui parce qu'en fait ils demandent
surtout que le fardeau qu'ils ont dû
supporter pour renflouer leurs banques
ne soient plus pris en compte dans la
dette de l'état
c'est un petit peu ce que demande chypre
aussi actuellement dans le cadre des
négociations pour un plan de sauvetage
et les espagnols voudra la même chose
par rapport aux recapitalisations des
banques
parce qu'il faut savoir que l'irlande
n'a pas été sauvée parce qu'elle avait
la grèce voilà ce n'est pas la grèce
avait pas une dette de 150 % en fait
c'est juste qu'elle a du jour au
lendemain trouver 32% de son pib pour
renflouer ses banques et elle dit comme
c'était pour les banques
je veux pas que ça soit dans ma dette
publique et suite à l'explosion de la
bulle immobilière effectivement ils ont
dû nationaliser
tout se servant des hommes qui veulent
sortir de leurs comptes publics
et c'est un petit peu pourquoi eux ils
vont vraiment poussé sur l'union
bancaire pour mettre en place la
supervision par la banque centrale
européenne est ensuite négocier la
création de fonds communs de dead pour
les banques dans l'est dans les caf
futur mais le veulent un petit peu
revient sur le passé aussi d'accord
alors le programme de la présidence
irlandaise c'est comme on peut s'en
douter relance de l'emploi et croissance
au fond c'est comme d'habitude un peu
mais en six mois ils feront comme
d'habitude surtout je veux dire gérer
les réunions au fur et à mesure mais
surtout ce qui va les occuper c'est
qu'il ya trois autres gros dossiers
actuels manquent qui sont là le budget
2014 2020 de l'union européenne ce qu'on
appelle les perspectives financières
il faut un accord assez rapidement pour
pouvoir négocier les deux prochains qui
sont la réforme de la politique agricole
commune et la réforme de la politique
régionale et ça il faut que ça est assez
rapidement parce que comme ça doit
rentrer en place le 1er janvier prochain
il faut que le budget soit en gros
décidé pour le printemps pour qu'après
on puisse terminer deux autres réformes
et après les transposer au niveau
national donc on va dire que l'irlande a
aussi intérêt à être un très bon
conciliateur entre les positions des
états les positions du parlement et
jouer un rôle de facilitateur et alors
est ce que l'irlande va réussir à faire
rester son voisin le royaume uni dans le
giron européen on sait que david cameron
doit s'exprimer sur la question
est ce que est ce qu'on voit ce qu'on en
est à ce niveau là car on doit faire son
discours normalement vendredi 18 janvier
l'irlande a pas forcément un grand poids
m'en sépare donc eu lien n'est pas dans
schengen en partie parce que son voisin
britannique ne l'est pas l'irlande n'a
jamais eu comme idée de sortir de
l'union européenne encore on a entendu
le premier ministre au moment de la
prise
la présidence a dit on doit beaucoup de
choses à notre intégration à l'union
européenne
ces deux visions totalement différente
donc cameron lui répond à une pression
d'opinions publiques et une partie de
son de son parti conservateur mais on
sait qu'il fera pas de référendum sur
l'appartenance même à mon avis il fera
un référendum éventuellement 2015 2016
mais ça sera plus sûr est ce que vous
voulez qu'on renégocie notre
appartenance les traiter quelque chose à
faire pour qu'ils puissent négocier
quelque chose mais s'en sortir parce que
c'est pas dans l'intérêt même la city
aujourd'hui commencent à s'inquiéter de
l'idée que le royaume uni pourrait
sortir de l'union européenne donc je
pense pas qu'il ira jusqu'au clash
ultime
merci jean sébastien pour toutes ces
informations on va maintenant dans un
pays que vous connaissez très bien c'est
la belgique où là bas le mariage
homosexuel a été légalisé en 2003 sans
que cela pose finalement beaucoup de
problèmes par rapport au débat qu'on
peut connaître aujourd'hui en france
donc avant de retrouver kathia gilder et
son invité direction la belgique avec
flora sauvage
en couple depuis neuf ans à nevers l'ont
choisi de se marier dans quelques mois
elles vont se dire oui devant leur
famille et leurs amis comme n'importe
quel couple depuis 2003 en belgique
le mariage est ouvert à tous y compris
aux personnes de même sexe en a toujours
dit quand on a des enfants on voulait
des enfants voire sont mariés c'est
aussi pour dire aux gens aux amis qu'on
a vraiment choisi pour la pour l'autre
derrière ce mariage d'amour c'est aussi
un moyen de protéger leurs enfants
si l'une ou l'autre des ced pour elle le
mariage est un droit fondamental auquel
tous les citoyens doivent avoir accès et
make-up quelqu'un ça n'a rien à voir
avec le sexe c'est vraiment aimé un nom
un être humain et même si c'est un homme
ou une femme
il faut être vraiment ouvert et dire
c'est la même chose c'est vraiment la
même chance tu veux que tout le monde à
la fois pour sa verve et la maman
biologique des deux enfants 6 qui a
trois ans et y est sa petite soeur sont
issus d'un don de sperme
ici en belgique depuis une trentaine
d'années la procréation médicalement
assistée est accessible à toutes les
femmes y compris aux lesbiennes
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être stérile
pour y avoir accès j'ai dû même grâce à
la loi sur l'adoption votée en 2006 anna
pu adopter les enfants et devenir leur
mère au même titre que sa compagne le
doigt dans l'adoption
même plus plus important pour nous pour
que la loire de la mariage parce que
c'est vraiment important que le un peu
reconnaît les enfants parce que quand il
arrive quelque chose avec moi qu'il va
se confier la maison font en belgique
dix ans après le vote de la loi
le mariage homosexuel est entré dans les
moeurs un millier de mariage de même
sexe sont célébrés chaque année ce qui
représente 2 % des unions civiles
en 2003 le sujet n'a quasiment pas fait
débat
plus que le mariage c'est la question de
la filiation et de l'adoption qui ont
suscité des résistances
karine lalieux est députée fédérale
socialiste elle a voté en faveur de la
loi sur le mariage gay les socialistes
et la majorité des partis flamands
s'ouvrent les partis flamands catholique
était pour directement ouvrir aussi à
l'adoption
mais il ya eu un veto du parti libéral
en disant si adoption il y aura pas de
mariage alors qu'on avait une majorité
pour faire adopter au démarchage en même
temps nous avons cédé nous avons fait
uniquement le mariage qui était déjà un
premier pas face aux réticences le choix
a été fait de séparer la question du
mariage et celle de l'adoption au siège
de cette association de défense des
droits des homosexuels ou salue l'action
des politiques
c'était une volonté stratégique aussi du
pouvoir politique à l'époque de ne pas
faire passer les deux loups en même
temps donc ils ont attendu quelques
années puis en 2006 ils ont fait passer
la loi sur l'adoption qui étaient
intégrés quelque part aussi à une
révision de la loi qui existait déjà
puisqu'ils ont revu l'adoption
intrafamiliales et de dons
ils ont rajouté que les couples homos
avait aussi droit à l'adoption
l'objectif était de donner un cadre
légal aux enfants vivant dans des
familles homoparentales présents dans
l'hémicycle lors du passage de la loi
sur l'adoption par les homosexuels
ce sociologue raconte comment s'est
déroulé le vote autant le vote sur le
mariage a été très consensuel avec le
cas à peu près unique au monde deux
démocrates-chrétiens flamands qui était
dans l'opposition à ce moment là qu'ils
avaient perdu le pouvoir ont voté
majoritairement en faveur de la loi sur
le mariage qui est assez étonnant pour
un parti d'origine catholique et donc la
loi sur le mariage et passe assez
facilement la loi sur l'adoption est
passé très juste et malgré les
réticences de certains le débat en
belgique s'est passé dans un climat
apaisé sans aucune manifestation
désormais plus personne ne remette en
cause le mariage ou l'adoption par les
homosexuels
je crois qu'il est important à un moment
donné que le politique en matière
éthique précède la société assume des
choix assume d inventer sociétal même si
à une opposition à la société parce
qu'on voit après que si il ya une
normalisation et bien ça ça calme toutes
les passions
la belgique est devenue le deuxième pays
au monde après les pays bas à légaliser
le mariage et l'adoption pour les
personnes de même sexe l'espagne la
suède ou le portugal ont suivi en europe
aujourd'hui sept pays autorise le
mariage homosexuel
reportage signé flora sauvage un autre
pays à légaliser il ya quelques années
le mariage homosexuel c'est l'espagne un
invité est avec nous justement pour en
parler
et pas n'importe qui juan fernando lopez
aguilar
vous étiez au moment de l'adoption de la
loi ministre de la justice du
gouvernement zapatero cette loi
espagnole
vous l'avez un peu porter alors vous
êtes ici aussi le président de la
commission des libertés et de la justice
du parlement européen
revenons à cette époque à 2005
comment s'est passée l'adoption de la
loi qui a eu autant d'oppositions qu'en
france il ya eu bien sûr de possession
mais il faut tout d'abord rappeler qu'il
s'agissait d'un engagement explicite de
la plateforme électorale avec laquelle
on a remporté les élections en 2004
alors et s'agissait aussi d'un test de
crédibilité que la force des bois à pau
changer l'école les choses on a dit on
va établir le mariage homosexuel et
passe en deuxième choix
alors on a fait exactement ça exactement
pour démontrer que les besoins allez
pouvoir dé changer la législation
on a dû expliquer bien sûr qu'en espagne
les droits des mariages c'est
hétérosexuels des mariages civils des
mariages religieux est toujours
respectée bien sûr mais il y a aussi
dans ce site est ouverte est plus réelle
d autres choix qui ont besoin d'une
solution législative c'est exactement
que qu'on a fait pourtant la société
espagnole est quand même très catholique
on peut penser qu'ils aient eu encore
plus de débats et de position qu'en
france est ce que vous comprenez les
vives critiques qui s'élèvent les
manifestations en france qui ont eu lieu
à quelques jours vous les comprenez bien
sûr l'église catholique a été une agence
d'opposition très forte ensemble au
parquet a en parti populaire à la droite
et à l'extrême droite en espagne mais il
faut les expliquer il faudrait expliquer
que 1 espagne dans le code civil
les mariages religieux et respecter et à
des effets civile reconnue par la
législation civile espagnole ça veut
dire que l'espagne est parfaitement
parfaitement légitime dépense et qu'ils
ont c'est marie seulement une fois pour
tout la vie jusqu'à la morte devant dieu
ça c'est une choix absolument légitime
mais il y à aussi en espagne d autres
personnes qui ont droit à une solution
législative différents pour faire des
mariages tout simplement un con trat
juridique avec des effets avec l'une des
solutions et ça avec sans discrimination
pour récente d'orientation sexuelle et
c'est exactement comment est ce que vous
pensez que le mariage doit être un droit
fondamental comme on l'a entendu avec
l'un des acteurs de ce reportage
des personnes dans l'espagne en fait
l'ailé mariage est un droit fondamental
protégé par la constitution et c'est
tellement jeu pour ça que dans une
députation du côté sale de même sexe ou
non leurs dons dans une interprétation
extrêmement conservatrice la droite les
partis populaires a porté un recours
dans constitutionnel d'avant la crise
d'abord la cour des comptes et
constitutionnel les remaniements a
rapporté récemment cetc cause devant la
cour constitutionnelle pour que la
conséquence de cela a déclaré park se
demande valide les la constitution
établit espagnol établi les droit
fondamental au mariage sans
discrimination entre l'homme et la femme
est l'essence de cette déclaration
constitutionnelle n'est pas limité les
mariages seulement à l'homme à la femme
et des haies et interdire que il y à des
discriminations à l'intérieur de m des
mariages gay c'est exactement la
situation d'avant la constitution
pendant le franquisme les franquisme la
dictature franquiste en espagne la femme
perdait ses droits civils mais pas par
l'effet des mariages ça c'est interdit
par la constitution mais la constitution
espagnole lente
hardy pas que la législation civile peut
établir un mariage homosexuel à mariage
des personnes de même sexe que c'est que
ce que c'est ce qu'on a fait oui c'est
ce qu'on a fait ce que vous avez fait
puisque vous étiez le ministre de la
justice du gouvernement qui a fait
passer la loi
est ce qu'aujourd'hui elle est entrée
dans les moeurs est ce que ait plus
personne ne s'y oppose en espagne en
tout cas est ce qu'elle est rentrée dans
les moeurs la réponse oui affirmatif pas
de doute sur sa mine à l'intérieur des
partis populaires nîmes à l'intérieur
des forces conservatrices qui se sont
opposés dans la rue ou dans des
manifestations en déportation ce sont
des bruits l'église catholique tout tout
tout le monde et peut tout simplement
vérifier que les mariages homosexuels
les marins tp sont des vingt-sept à
l'espagne et socialement acceptée passé
le monde dans les sondages 60% des
jambes de la population de la société
espagnole dit oui au mariage des
personnes de même sexe mais surtout sur
les moeurs sur la vie quotidienne
on a normalisé ses membres d'aider vivre
ensemble et s'effondre aussi de faire
partie d'une société ouverte aux lianes
et plurielle alors en france quand on a
évoqué la question du mariage on a
évoqué aussi celle de l'adoption est
celle du recours à l'assistance médicale
à la procréation est ce que pour vous
c'est trois questions
doivent être traitées ensemble ou est ce
qu'elle va faire l'objet de lois
différentes en espagne a eu par exemple
des lois différentes votées sur ce sujet
où tout est comment ça se passe non ce
n'est pas le cas on fait il s'agit d'une
question j'aurais dit que même technique
en espagne c'est ce qu'on a fait est
tout simplement modifié l'article du
code civil concernant l'institution du
mariage
on n'a pas touché l'adoption que c'est
un chapitre est tout à fait différent
dans les comptes civile c'est ce qu'on a
fait et n'est pas introduire une
discrimination objectif pour des raisons
d' orientation sexuelle pour interdire
des personnes homosexuelles de faire
partie d'une procédure d'adoption
on a mal nourris sourire à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et bien sûr ça
veut dire aussi ça veut dire aussi qu en
espagne où on paie fait partie des
procédures d'adoption quand données
célibataire et quand on est marié
quels que soient et quel que soit l'état
à ce qu'elle soit l'état civil
on peut faire partie d'un possédez des
notions alors en espagne il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui ont fait adoption en
étant célibataire
la seule façon d prévenir keane couple
est homosexuel peut faire partie de
posséder des actions et d interdire aux
bières clic manque un couple de
personnes de même sexe peut faire partie
d'un poster d'adoption et ça veut dire
attendez une discrimination vis-à-vis
les personnes qui font partie en étant
célibataire
on n'a pas interdit ça alors les faits
ça a été élargir la possibilité de faire
partie des procédures d'adoption on est
à un couple de même sexe
merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage très
intéressant et c'est donc la fin
d'europe et deux on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles avec
françois beaudonnet très bonne suite de
programmes